with guru Crowder that's right that's
the sound of uh well for people who are
too many people who were not mug club
members by the first time uh Club we
have a very significant steep discount
steep discount so something is steep
people don't know it's a show that we do
this often every other Monday depending
Mass Monday usually my half-asian where
it's not here should we just me and
Gerald and you can send your requests
for life advice at life advice at
laterals credit com yes a lot of these
yeah a lot of keys yeah lottie's and by
the way this is the time that I should
warn you of course that if you are
having any serious thoughts of self-harm
to seek professional counseling I'm not
a doctor that being said doctors look at
me with urine with longing in their eyes
they do longing because I'm a mail-order
guru
so I actions a higher estriol and in
some ways that's more important than a
doctor
especially minces crisis yeah yeah we
don't have enough gurus I'm available
I'm gonna do a drinking game
what's that every time you pop those
papers I'm gonna drink oh that's fine
you don't need you don't need my excuse
to drink by the way it is filled to the
brim
every tires whiskey every time so okay
let's get to your letters a dear senior
guru Lord of all gurus only yielding to
the true Almighty God wow that's but do
I yield you should um I am a high school
student and I have a brain disorder
right oh yeah the disorder causes me to
be bothered by repetitive sounds things
like chewing gum
breathing heavily tapping a pencil etc
just really set me off well see when you
say really set me off the etc is kind of
important yeah turn the microwave on and
the family turns up dead on the news and
exhale
I don't like this is not an etc etc yeah
extrapolate and other thing and the
other thing and things of that nature
and so on and whatnot I know it sounds
like I'm making this up but bear with me
I first noticed it when I found other
people eating with their mouths open
annoying when we all do yeah see that's
how this whole pandemic got started well
and food falls out seems logical enough
however this progressed into being such
a problem that my brain turns to anger
when these things occur it has really
affected my relationships with my
parents as to the point where it is
almost impossible to have a sit to have
a quiet sit-down meal with my family I
want to know what you would have to say
about this
keep up the shows or awesome fellow mug
clubber JCR I don't know what that
stands for I don't have a whole lot to
say about this if you haven't been
diagnosed and like I know I find it
annoying when people eat with their
mouth open or chew gum with their mouths
open yeah but I don't fear my own
capabilities at that point as to what I
could carry out your etc is limited Yeah
right whereas this one may not be my etc
like what what do I do when someone's
chewing with their mouths open my etc is
like stop cut it out yours might involve
a trip to the shed machetes in your
freezer I don't know you mean you got
you've got you've got a couple of good
options here which is doing the whole
counting method right right someone's
getting it's the normal anger management
techniques yeah there's also that just
leave the room and punch wall and not
once a wall with someone in between you
and the right right yeah that's a good
idea or if you have the reach like
Gerald make sure there's nobody on the
other side of the world that's true
right one time you just hit a contractor
I mean he's just right to people but you
know it was this thing of anger
management when I was when I was a early
in my marriage I've always struggled
with with anger issues and sometimes
I've talked about this as a man
sometimes you get mad for your wife but
it seems like you're getting mad at your
wife you know we've talked about that a
woman who was sort of bored a co-worker
who's borderline abusive and you get mad
and then you realize there's not really
much you can do because you can't go
into your wife's place of work same
thing I'm sure if you have kids but one
thing I also said that it's really
helped me with
in counseling I try to do this for a
while people talk about Transcendental
Meditation I don't I still don't know
what that means I know guided meditation
is so lazy I had the other place simple
habit and this lady was talking about
going to sleep she was supposed to be
guiding me through meditation because
and you find yourself that is sterile I
swear to you I don't know if is still on
there you find yourself at a stereo and
although you know sounds increase alpha
waves the stairwell could be made of
wood or another material
I think meditation is made to seem a
little more complicated than it is you
know this this is sort of in creating a
barrier to entry like I've kind of
talked about sometimes with the CDC
where people feel as though they can't
get the the right information everything
that they say is wrong like trying to
use Everclear to sanitize something oh
yeah you have to go through all the
documents they say yeah but it's more
expensive enhancing it as well I didn't
ask you a budgetary question there is no
an sanitizer your work it can um same
thing with meditation where people try
to make it sound more complicated than
it really is really meditation is folk
is clearing your mind or you can choose
to use that time to focus on something
specific and breathing is important so I
will say this is an exercise that it's
definitely helped me use breathe in for
count so breathe in fill your belly fill
your chest and breathe out with a seven
count so yeah breathe in and breathe out
and so you have to create a little bit
of pressure some some people say go some
people go say go
some people say go but the point is you
want that you want because your pulse
lowers when exhaling what if you go to
the contrary to win inhale so simple
breathing and doing that ten times
counting I it has helped me a lot when I
get a little overwhelmed yeah quiet
place yeah breathe and then if you go
back and the sound still bother you you
should probably avoid the wet food
market and yeah is it wet food what is
it wet blood what's the food live food
markets they're where they see the live
animals anyway the whole reason for the
coronavirus the wet blood I don't know
what they call China I don't know where
you
China right okay okay all right so dear
guru Crowder look that helps my
girlfriend and I and I hope I don't do
ASMR fun sorry no etc etc I hope you
like a safe place gosh she's like my dog
and they will the night I'm like really
right now you got to be doing that well
yeah he does know keep it up clearance
alright
clintus alright dear guru Crowder my
girlfriend and i have been going through
our political views recently which has
led to some turmoil I'm a Christian and
my political views tend to follow my
religious beliefs my girlfriend was
raised a Christian but this does not
believe because she was forced into
christened him by her parents since her
falling away from the faith she has put
her political views into two main
categories women's rights mostly
abortions and environmental concerns
don't like her right she is more central
on most topics but would rather have
abortions legal even after birth and
illegal altogether that's murder yeah
that's crazy I am searching for guidance
in this trying time dear guru especially
since we have talked about marriage in
recent months what should I do with
someone I love but is also against most
things I stand well obviously jail you
should answer this but first don't marry
the axe murderer yes especially when she
broadcasts I am an axe murderer before
the marriage right
so he's leading with murder yes yes she
should save that one for last so hey
look I get it
honestly what my answer to this for
anybody who is serious about this if you
have such an opposing view on something
like abortion on environmental issues
you can say ah well I think the
environment you know they're over
blowing it but we should take care of
the environment somebody else's like
yeah I think the environment needs to be
taken care of too but I think we need to
be much more involved and you can still
kind of reconcile those two things
pretty has Bayesian Bill breeze like a
pug
does he really don't do the breathing I
don't do the breathing exercises into
the microphone
the repetitive guy that we just talked
about said breathing stop he just killed
somebody he doesn't care about him I'm
gonna stop breathing that's true okay
well not altogether now bill all right
so you can reconcile I think
environmental differences a little bit
easier when it comes down to abortion
even after birth to make sure like that
I feel like and say even after birth
it's what she say particularly after
yeah so I mean when something
that you're acting conciliatory like
even though it's early like even the
morning after even close not toning
drawers okay yeah I was going for like
are you serious
even after birth right that's what I was
trying to say okay I don't think there's
a really good way of reconciling the the
opinions that you have to hold for that
to be okay right that there's got to be
some underlying things there that you
guys are just not gonna line up on and
it's gonna be a great source of conflict
every time we have to answer my
questions and I appreciate it life
advice at a lot of credit calm we've
answered this many times like you cannot
someone will bring out they'll trot out
some individuals who are like James
Carville and I always forget the name of
his wife Oh a Democrat and Republican as
a general rule it is close to impossible
to have a long term successful marriage
and raise a family when you are on
complete opposite ends of the political
spectrum because usually that's
representative of your values
particularly as it relates to
fundamental issues like life for example
you may both be Christians or you may
both be atheist or you maple you may
differ on fiscal policy one of you may
think that a marginal tax rate of fifty
two percent is fine one you may think
it's forty eight percent one you may
think we should increase that's
different from the fundamental world
view as to whether life is valuable or
not right and in both of these incidents
by the way I don't want to get into this
so much right now because it's life
advice show but abortion and sort of the
neo environmentalist movement they're
both anti people and they're both an
extremely tide when you look at the idea
of population control you look at
eugenics this is something that the Left
believes aoc goes on a live stream and
says people feel anxiety should they
have children because it's a moral
dilemma in this in this climate change
riddled world well actually it's it's
not it's not a moral dilemma and if you
are and I'm maybe it maybe for you but
it shouldn't be what the person who's
going to be your spouse it cannot be a
moral dilemma for one and not the other
it can't work long-term and I don't
understand how people are picking these
relationships yeah what you have to have
the same film tastes in common you both
like board games we always try to find
in common that that don't really matter
what matters is how you view the world
at what matters are your fundamental
principles and if they join up
particularly if you're talking about
creating a family unit and the raising
and rearing of children this is not I
don't even that you shouldn't even be
considering marriage whatsoever yeah I
wouldn't think so and I not until you
get some resolution to this if she if
she just doesn't understand what she's
saying and she's making
an argument from an emotional point like
I'm a feminist right and doesn't really
understand what she's saying that's
different then I know what I'm talking
about
I've researched this it should be legal
even after birth yeah it's crazy that
sounds crazy base even know how she
bones people walk that back if I drink
your advice Academy Award nomination
yeah so she Daniel day-lewis Daniel
day-lewis has he ever done anything not
over-the-top just understated Lincoln Oh
for crying out loud
over the top of course it's over the top
you're sitting there Norman let's look
at the butcher in gangs of timid actual
killed boy and then you look at there
will be blood shake all spirit right
into the emotional state Daniel
day-lewis he's like yeah I can be there
tomorrow I'm already ready has anyone
gone back and watch my blood alcohol is
literally like 9% of how many times
you've popped I really don't want it I'm
not used to a physical paper I construe
have you gone unpack them seen less than
Mohicans recently it's been a while it's
just a short action film that ends
that's it most action films everyone
thinks of it as this picturesque Academy
worthy picture just a guy throwing a
tomahawk around and then you're like
okay I guess it's Daniel day-lewis and
some sweet mother my feathered
Leathernecks one dear guru of all gurus
thank you appreciate
I did have to I'd have to send it with
two stamps my son is 10 years old and I
have started to talks with him about
drugs and sex okay wow that's the first
off ten is a little late for sex it's a
little early for drugs like waiting to
celebrate birthdays that are close you
just go in the middle like you need to
have these separate talks yeah it's
strictly it's like that's what they do
in Detroit you know like when you're a
kid you go in the beach and you have the
Metall finest yes you find a coin silver
dollar they do that with crack right in
the vein that's Detroit listen Pete
don't people raise her kids differently
beetroots geographical differences we
don't wanna be that show that's out of
touch it's true right we don't you do
you I was telling him that a man and
woman don't have sex until they're
married and he called me out my wife and
I have been together since the 10th
grade about 15 years we have two
children but were not married until
after the first child well you made it
easy for a little bit this point I mean
if he's 10 if the kid can do basic
additions and subtractions well if he
knows his multiplication tables if he's
done his flashcards you are screwed how
can I tell him what's right when I did
not follow my own advice in the past any
hell any and all help is appreciated
thank you
PS well the show that al-qaeda is part
of my daily routine well we appreciate
it and that's why I wanted to make this
avail to as many people as possible for
this month while they are in quarantine
um so I will say this my parents did the
same thing because they were not
Christians when they got married
no they didn't they didn't fudge the
math like they we were born after they
had been married and I would have been
able to do the math nine months okay but
they then became Christians and then
they obviously have shared these views
that that that we hold on the idea of
waiting until you're right and I've
written about this pretty extensively so
they framed it in a way when they taught
me and said listen the right way to do
it is when a man and a woman really love
each other and they decide they want to
spend the rest of their lives with one
another they get married and then they
explained sex to me in no uncertain
terms I knew exactly what it was I got
into trouble in preschool because they
were giving us the stork story and I
said mrs. Anderson that's not true
let me break this down for you
and I got in trouble you know why cuz
her daughter was in my class and she was
telling she had the shitty lie alive
from when she went home with her
daughter so she reprimanded me in front
of the class what is this
and I like I knew this is a kid because
I had to learn except the one thing my
parents never explained to me was what a
vagina looks like so I still believe
that it was where the wiener was like in
the front so I was like I thought I was
like a hole and the front like death
becomes her of course anyway
the point I'm making here is to frame
this discussion how you want with your
children you don't get to frame how
authentically you get to have a
pro-choice well this guy definitely
doesn't because he already screwed the
pooch on that look if you're gonna talk
about these issues and no one can claim
the moral high ground you can still use
it to say hey I made mistakes in here
let me or I made something that I now
believe is wrong and I want to talk to
you about it or here's why didn't you
can speak from place because one thing
that you often hear not at least I heard
a lot in church growing up was oh well
my parents were perfect they never did
anything wrong like I don't even know
about living life right and whereas a
lot of the parents when you later would
find out like they did live life they
chose the life that they live now in the
moral path that the wrong walking on
because they had gone the wrong way and
that doesn't mean that everyone has to
go one way so that they can realize what
the moral path is right but you can use
those as examples to say I'm a real
person I'm trying to help you learn from
my own mistakes as opposed to being like
yeah no we didn't do it but dad you told
me that in 1987 you met at a Christian
youth retreat i presenting sebin a girls
gone wild is that not you licking your
son Bourbon Street for beads first wow
wow that is you licking your debts on
girls gone wild for I was wonder
whatever I saw those but you look at
children good example this my parents my
dad had never Darney drugs ever yeah
he's very honest about it my mom had
smoked pot and stuff as a kid and when
they talk to me about drugs they were
very honest about it my dad
I have never done it I would tell you if
I had your mom has this is why you don't
want to do it particularly when you're
young you know and they same thing when
they had the conversations about alcohol
or sex they framed it and we're tried to
be as transparent as possible
and then explain why the way they wanted
me to do it was the right way and not
just the right way in some abstract
sense because when you're yelling you
can't always understand the philosophy
behind it but why it was beneficial to
me in ways that I would be able to
actually understand and quantify yeah
and it equips your child to be able to
make a choice right right instead of
just saying well this is what my mom and
dad do know I understand that my dad or
my mom didn't do it this way but they
also either experienced the consequences
of that action were very lucky not to
right and good advice is good advice
whether it's followed or not it doesn't
change that the advice is good it's just
hard to get your your kid probably to
understand that if you constantly just
tell them as though you were perfect
throughout your whole life so I think
that right but don't lie to your kids I
mean isn't like there's like a hundred
movies 100 movies that come out a year
that are like if I only I had told you
the truth about the thing I had done
before and the reason why I was getting
advice is because I live through the
problem like if you've watched any of
those movies just know it's not good to
just wait and not talk about it right go
back to the same exam all of the movies
were the like if I had only shared this
one back story about this thing that
I've been helping you to stay away from
right think one were the mayor's July
weekend probably what are you talking
about I've seen that we should have
listened that shit'll listen what do you
have another experience with the shark
oh right Gerald Morgan hope that helps
better back home dear guru Crowder I'm
honestly not sure where to turn for this
question because everyone's getting
called that one too soon sir
yeah foreshadowing but the other day my
girlfriend revealed that two years ago
she cheated on me and fooled around with
an ex for about three months it was a
pretty serious relationship we had been
dating since high school
whoo they didn't technically have sex
technically I'm glad use that term so
and we now know the ex is Bill Clinton
yes but still fooled around and on top
of that I had been ring shopping
recently I'm just unsure if I can trust
her again and if the relationship can
manage to get through this or even if
it's worth
to fix I'm just a complete loss of what
to do on one hand hit someone I care
deeply for and was even probably going
to get engaged to on the other hand she
did not completely know she did sorry
yeah thank you madly betray that's a big
sticking point right there I was focused
on the lack of punctuation I'm sorry oh
it's distracted any it is be white
diamond or cheated greatly alright so
this is this is a this is a tough one
because for some people I wouldn't say
some I would say for most people this
stuff this is the line pretty
wishy-washy right now now listen I know
that I know that there are some people
out here out there who can get past
something like that in a relationship
but it's very very hard if I married yes
I agree with that and but you know other
people this is just a deadline you can't
you can't get past this and that's not
gonna happen and I would I would fall on
that side where it's like if somebody
before marinating yeah I would I would
probably just be out because I don't
know that I could ever trust that / if
you're gonna do it while we're dating
entirely different advice I agree people
healed from infidelity in marriage now
especially and can't context really go
back to other life advice we've talked
about that if it's a one-time deal
someone makes a mistake yeah some people
can't get past it but a lot of marriages
right have that can happen and it is
important ticular if you have children
to try and see what your options are and
see how you can potentially fix a
relationship that's fractured that being
said right now you are entering into a
relationship with eyes wide open where
you know that this is a possibility the
system has betrayed your trust
yeah it wouldn't for me it's pretty
simple it wouldn't be worth it no I
wouldn't because you're always going to
have that second-guess like oh wait a
minute she was late she's been at the
office a few times like it's always
gonna be this seed that sticks let's
change is the context a whole lot yeah
yeah it's not like she went out on a
girls night right and she had too much
to drink and on the way home and they
were stopping at Vaughn's to get a pint
at Penn & Jerry's she slept with a bag
boy it's not something like it's like
this is an ex when she still had it was
quite a detailed story you're never
gonna let me forget about the bag
your water you're a guy's lawyer for
three years you think you can forget
about what are you doing with a grocer
you could do better it was a lot of fun
[Applause]
it like the rest of us so so I would I
think the there's no bones about it
if you if this person doesn't feel like
they can trust yeah yeah that's right
you definitely got to put any marriage
consideration on pause you're more
likely not going to be able to regrow
that trust if you're right in the mind
that you're gonna say there's only one
person out there for you you're not
married you you you you've still got the
opportunity to be able to figure that
out right as hard as that may be and
maybe you've gotten to the point where
you you are past it and you truly are
but if there is a harboring there that
harboring will more likely than not
given that it's a pre-marriage not to
get any better and will likely only get
worse and - by the way we don't know you
that two years ago she cheated on me
with an ex for about three months it was
a pretty serious relationship if if you
think by the way if you think that you
can get past it I still wouldn't let her
know I still wouldn't hand her an
engagement ring yeah yeah a little bit
make her jump through hoops you know
like like a dolphin at SeaWorld but I am
saying she should have to earn back your
trust even if you are looking for a
reason to forgive her because sometimes
we've done this you know especially it's
like with parents with kids you want to
excuse the inexcusable behavior because
you love them and maybe right it's cute
and you were looking for a reason to
forgive them and that's great and you
can still forgive this person without
being in a toxic relationship with them
but if you do find yourself wanting to
be in a relationship but I think all of
us have advised against don't tell her
that right away because you're giving
her carte blanche to just do this going
forward yeah you can't be you can't get
walked over again like two years two
years for three months with an ex as an
ongoing
no absolutely not yeah the more mad I
get I don't I don't carry she ate that
you called me guru I'm not mad with you
I'm not mad at you I meant for you yeah
there you go just being clear and your
behalf yeah by the way that was reading
the article I think was at Slate or
salon or someone sent in a request for
advice saying I caught my boyfriend
playing with himself to an old video of
his ex-girlfriend was cheating and
should I stop dating him and the person
responded well my biggest concern is
that that is a violation of consent
because I bet you as ex girlfriend
doesn't wanna I'm like that's your
that's that's concern it's retroactive
removal of consent listen if they both
took the video together like they would
both have deleted unless it was like
[Music]
nothing good comes from slate or salon
aside from our beds from pedophiles
there you go and do your research so
long we were the ones who highlighted
the salon pedophile looking for three
times on the pedophile but I'm not a
monster they tried to hide that
should've been read it should have been
titled differently yeah I'm a pedophile
stop
[Music]
blast one then we do have to keep going
hi Steven no I don't know no goo got a
last name I mean is it Wow I want to
start off by saying that your show gave
me a reason to wake up on Thursday
mornings there's any more interesting
okay but it's at night is it from here
[Music]
by the way did I tell you I try to
download land down under from was it men
at work yes but instead on Spotify the
first thing that pops up is men working
mmm-hmm yeah it's it's not original no
no it's just it's like land down under I
think this isn't the same tempo is it
was like men who are working it's a
ghost track of the workmen yes hi Steven
I'm uh waking up on Thursday night I'd
like to hear your advice on how to make
people remember you what would you say
to a person whose classmates don't even
remember your name after you've worked
with them for months I'll admit that
this struggle or whatever the hell you
should call it is probably largely due
to my shitty personality but in asking
for your advice
all right listen I I don't know that's
the case I can tell you this I had a
tremendously B personality but people
remembered me for that
I was gonna say if you have a thin line
between famous and infamous it's true
just not memorable I'm thinking it might
be helpful for certain people like
bosses and co-workers to know who I am
if you've wasted this much time by
reading this whole thing I appreciate it
i also appreciate race okay first off
listen that's I won't read the name down
you've got to develop a little bit of
confidence sweetheart it's oh it's a
girl here you saying you've wasted this
much time by reading this whole thing
here's the thing and I don't want to
come down on you because obviously it
sounds like you don't necessarily have a
great self-image here that being said
sometimes that's a defense mechanism and
I send us who I have used a defense
mechanism of humor my entire life
sometimes to try and shield myself from
myself from emotions or at least from
showcasing them to people who may not be
in my close circle front so I understand
defense mechanisms but saying like oh I
suck nobody likes me I have a crappy
personality is a way for you to kind of
get to that insult before somebody else
does and it can become a crutch that's
what I'm seeing written all over your
letter here outside of that listen you
don't know how many people remember you
or don't and that is true there are some
people who are quiet and they're less
memorable than other people but yeah
what really matters is the people who do
remember you what kind of impact do you
have on their life how close are you the
amount of impact that you make or the
volume of impact isn't what matters so
much as far as how many people you reach
and I understand the irony in that being
that I work in a role where we try to
reach as many people as possible
but the intimacy and the quality of your
relationships now if you find that
lacking as well that may mean that you
need to put yourself out there a little
bit more and if you put yourself out
there a little bit more what you can't
do is put yourself out there a little
more for people to like you and then
tell them that you don't even like
yourself now I'm not saying that you
need to be arrogant or cocky but you do
need to put your best foot forward and
believe in what it is that makes you
unique and believe in what it is that
makes you valuable what you bring to the
table
because other people will be able to
sense that on you and I think this is
another thing too with this whole alpha
culture I speak to men in the sense I
know you're a woman where people try to
talk about how to develop our like charm
channels how to develop charm how you
interact with how to make people like
you there are certainly ways to interact
with people some people may have an
abrasive communication style this guy
some people some people may be a little
bit quieter so you need to learn
to adapt yourself for certain social
situations that being said you cannot
teach somebody to be likable yeah in a
step-by-step process or through some
kind of a self-help book but my
experience most people have qualities
that are likable it's very rare that
somebody doesn't it's exceedingly rare
which is why some people at 10 Turks are
Marvel's they are and so I think you
defined what it is that makes you you
and willingly put that out there and
don't shut it down as a method of
preemptively doing so before someone
else can because I'm seeing that a
little bit well and I think too it's not
their fault that they don't remember you
if you are with classmates and
co-workers and you find this to be a
problem it's not the other people's
fault you probably aren't engaging all
on
you're probably withdrawing from these
circles of people and then when you go
back into them you're kind of surprised
that people don't remember you it's I
don't think it's necessarily a bad or a
good thing but if you desire people to
remember you and maybe engaged a little
bit more you got to go you got to go out
there you got to find out what people
are interested you got to talk to people
you've got to care about what's going on
in their world before they're gonna care
about what's going on in your world
sometimes so yeah just just go do that
and don't worry about it you know one
thing that I would say is really I've
seen used very successfully for people
who are introverts or kind of money yeah
that certainly helps yeah that can help
also having a 9 foot long revolver right
yeah so is when you go and talk to
someone I see the letters same waist
even this which is it was kind of a limp
in and a limp out right your life I'm
here but don't worry I'll leave as
quickly as I can you'll never know I was
here yes
right like oh don't worry about my
letter is no big deal even if you get to
the end oh my gosh I can't believe you
read it and I'm out whereas that one of
the ways it's really successful is you
don't have you if you can share about
yourself there is something that you
have that you're not sharing with other
people that is likeable or interesting
or memorable yeah but the other way to
be memorable is not to have anything to
do about yourself but to listen to
people and remember them people will
remember people that remember them look
as crazy like a lot of people that I've
met I remembered a couple things about
them because I actually took an interest
in them and the next time I saw them I
reminded them and I asked them about it
and people will perk up their ears and
go oh my gosh yeah
what I remember about Suzy she
remembered me and then they because
remembering it's yeah that probably that
part too but I'm gonna guess not here
but that's but that's just one way it's
not necessarily about are they
remembering it's just going out and
putting yourself out and I was less I'm
guilty of this myself but inside let me
let me sort of explain this in
situations where I didn't want to be
liked or I wanted to be remembered badly
for example my wife we were going to a
gathering with a guy let's say friends
and/or family who might have been on the
more left side of the spectrum and I did
not particularly want to spend a ton of
time at this gallery and so I sat down
and just like you said like I have a
crappy personality I cut it off with the
past and I said if one of you is
expecting me to check my privilege
that's not gonna happen
I'm gonna go get the kids don't you just
like you know what I'm going to reject
myself before they reject me or you know
you just don't shower for a couple of
days you know I ran out of soap you can
find an excuse the point is it is tough
to put yourself out there but if you
don't you're never going to have any
relationships worth having you're never
if you don't take any risks in life in
general you're never gonna have a life
worth having so I understand why you do
that a lot of people have their own
different defense mechanisms but um I
couldn't even answer your question as
far as what you have that makes you
unique all you've told me is how crappy
your personality is and I'm willing to
bet that if you search deeply hard
enough you will find something worth
mining in a relationship for somebody
else almost everybody does there are
very few people who have no redeeming
qualities you just have to find them and
you have to put them on display for the
world to see ok this has been of course
the latest installment of tough love but
you can send your request for next week
again we're still keeping this going as
a quarantine is going on life advice at
latter with credit calm we will see you
tomorrow yeah